big tech is about power and and it's
also about virtue signaling it's about
showing that you're morally self
righteous and when they're driving
someone like Peter Thiel out saying you
are a heretic and and it's it's on view
after view after view that there is you
know it's interesting it's a religious
fervor it's become the new religion woke
'no siz and and by the way no one can be
to pure light like it i mean there's an
element of like Robespierre setting up
the the the guillotine where they will
come after someone is only 99 percent
woke well the one percent coming after
that if you look at Democrats today they
are the party of Silicon Valley
billionaires they are the party of Wall
Street tycoons they are the party of
power and resources and and Republicans
the party that I want to be a part of is
a blue-collar party we're the party of
Ohio steel workers we're the party of
single moms waiting tables we're the
party of teenage kids like my dad
washing dishes why because opportunity
is why the ability of people to have a
job and to work is powerful do you see
that as the ultimate irony of what's
happened with Silicon Valley is that I
think privately I mean I know a lot of
these guys privately they're
libertarians of course they are because
they want to create
they love competition and they want to
be taxed low so that their businesses
can thrive and then publicly what you
see them say is completely the reverse
well look I mean Silicon Valley is so
bad that you know Peter Beebe yeah
Peter has been a buddy of mine for for
25 yeah Peter and I were friends before
he
had made his money when Peter and I
became friends it was the mid-90s and he
was a corporate lawyer practicing law
so come Valley is so bad that Peter was
driven out of it I mean he's moved out
of Los Angeles like like it uh you know
something's wrong when you're coming to
LA for a safe haven from the left it's
and and there's big tech is about power
and and it's also about virtue signaling
it's about showing that you're morally
self righteous and when they're driving
someone like Peter Thiel out saying you
are a heretic and and it's it's on view
after view after view that there is you
know it's interesting it's a religious
fervor mm-hmm it's become the new
religion woek 'no siz and and by the way
no one can be too pure like like it i
mean there's an element of like
Robespierre setting up the the
guillotine where they will come after
someone is only 99 percent woke well the
one percent is coming after that yep and
in that well I see that with all with
all these Hollywood people right because
no matter how much they beg they think
it's gonna spare them but it's not gonna
be the angry Trump supporters who come
to burn down their mansions it's gonna
be these other guys no matter what
penance you offer them but that sort of
gets back to what I was asking you
before about do you think that because
the world view is bereft of anything
other than politics that the whole it
leaves actually it leaves you with you
know what people would say is a
god-shaped hole that there that there
there is no sort of spiritual anything
there so you become you become the very
thing that you hate in essence yeah I'm
not sure big tech hates at all that much
so so I actually think you know text
started out as you know and and by the
way my parents are both mathematicians
and computer programmers so I mean I was
raised in a techie world their small
business was a seismic data processing
company my parents were
I mean my mom started as a programmer in
1956 I mean really the dawn of computers
I think Tech started out you had people
let's say a Mark Zuckerberg dropped out
of college goes and starts Facebook you
know who they're just trying to build a
business and they're doing their own
thing and and and and big tech didn't
start out all that political mm-hmm
it was go you know hey you know play
foosball in the office and and you know
wear shorts and flip-flops and go
innovate and be disruptive did you know
the whole dis ruptor thing is a big part
of the ethos mm-hmm and early on I don't
see Silicon Valley as as deeply
political it's more recently and it's
it's it's a clothing of protection for
one thing these guys are the modern-day
robber barons I mean the vast amount of
wealth as these plutocrats live in you
know they're they're owning islands and
flying massive jets and and and just
they've got walls around those houses
don't hide they have and security with
guns
very confusing and it all becomes just I
actually don't think they cared that
much about this but they don't want to
be rejected by the mob mm-hmm
I think it's much more a protective
shield and the world of such social
media becomes self-reinforcing where you
know we used to have homogenizing
institutions of whether it was church or
school or the Rotary Club where you know
you might be a Democrat but you knew
some Republicans you might be a
Republican you knew some Democrats you
might be Christian or Jewish or Muslim
but you knew people of different faiths
and and it was not on social media now
anywhere disagrees gets unfriended and
it becomes this echo chamber where
everyone has the same view mm-hmm and
and when I look at our democracy I what
I worry
about is there aren't shared facts
anymore we're not the left is listening
to left-wing websites they're listening
to their own facts the right is
listening to right wing websites by the
way look Fox is every bit as one-sided
as biased as MSNBC is and neither one of
them are actually like having having an
objective conversation that I worry
about what that's doing our country do
you ever get invited on MSNBC anymore um
I haven't been in a while I mean I've
done Chris Matthews he's gone he's gone
yeah they drove him out you're right it
so the last time you were invited by the
guy who they took out last time I did it
Chris Hayes interviewed me we did a
thing called trip fest the Texas Tribune
does this big so I did an hour interview
and I agreed agreed to that which had a
good actually that was a good
substantive conversation and it's about
an hour long and it you know he came at
me pretty hard which is fine I mean that
if we're having a conversation that's a
step in the right direction so do you
miss I mean I think I know the answer is
but do you miss sort of the same blue
dog more centrist Democrat because I
think Biden was the last hope of that
thing that's what it strikes me as and
and clearly he's not going to be the
savior obviously for many reasons but
you know Jordan Peterson talks about
this a lot that you want this healthy
tension between the left and the right
and it's like look I know I'm new to the
right so maybe I don't see some of the
problems that you guys have been around
so you see but what I see is this pretty
diverse group of the real Trump people
the more libertarian people that are all
out that are all sort of trying to fight
for what the future is on the left I
just see purging do you miss the old
school you know I know JFK is before
your time but you miss an old school
Democrat Daniel Patrick Moynihan look
JFK is a great example scoop Jackson on
foreign policy who believed in standing
up to communists then that you look at
JFK I often quote JFK
you read his speeches for example what
he says on on religious liberty you read
his speeches on cutting taxes and where
he campaigned in 1960 on we're gonna cut
your taxes and we're gonna cut your
taxes that's gonna produce more jobs
more prosperity that's going to benefit
everyone those speeches he would be
driven out of the Democratic Party like
some crazy heretic today yeah you look
at the tax cut we passed in 2017 you
know how many Democrats voted for it the
house zero in the Senate zero
there was nobody I'll give you another
example one one that the media refused
to cover but it's one that I'm I got
very passionate about the Democrats
introduced a constitutional amendment in
the Senate to repeal the free speech
protections of the First Amendment now
this was following the Citizens United
case which citizens unites become this
totem so Hillary Clinton pledged every
justice I points gonna repeal Citizens
United Joe Biden said the same thing do
they know when they say that about what
the Supreme Court nominees are going to
do in the future that that's not really
how government works well everyone does
this across the board writing for
Democratic nominees it largely does yeah
so I've got a book that's coming out in
October called one vote away and it
talks about how one vote on the Supreme
Court can can change history if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell